hey guys how's it going so today I am
going to the university of Irvine
I just mean why why are you going there
are going back to school I'm definitely
not going back to school but I am going
to check out their eSports arena now
eSports is a thing can you guys believe
that the study sports people playing
competitive video games is a thing
that's a career path of course you
believe it because you're living it you
see it every day there's a chance that
you know somebody a friend of yours who
is playing competitively you probably
watch people who play competitive video
games you might actually be one of those
people who are competing competitively
and I think it is it's beautiful it
really is and I'm not saying this being
sarcastic because the first time that I
didn't think that eSports was a thing
was 17 years ago I did the math and I'm
oh gosh that's probably longer than some
of you have been alive but I was in high
school and we would go to LAN parties
mostly because the internet really
wasn't that good back then so being able
to play multiplayer games that was the
only way to do it you had to bring
computers to one person's house or go to
a cyber cafe where they had really good
internet to be able to play multiplayer
games and back then I was playing on
real tournament quick three I was never
really that into counter-strike no I
didn't play counter-strike but one of
our friends did his name it was Casey
and I will never forget one week in case
he was not at our land party and I was
so confused because Casey was always
there he was actually competing
competitively in a counter-strike
tournament and I could not believe it I
was like wait so there's a bigger land
party so there's not just eight or ten
of us all in a room there's hundreds of
people cook it was he was probably like
trying to explain to your parents now
that eSports is a thing but then it
would be it wasn't a thing I mean it was
but not the level that it is today I
mean more people are watching League of
Legends tournaments than real
traditional sports and I'm putting that
in quotes because I believe that eSports
and playing video games is just as
competitive as playing actual real
sports and people don't understand that
and that is something that I think is
just so crazy because when you're
watching super intense games now I come
from most of a Call of Duty background I
hosted a bunch of the Call of Duty of it
and it is so much fun even for people
who don't understand what's going on if
you have incredible commentators people
who are really trying to pull that game
together to make it understandable for
everyone it is so much fun to watch and
I am just I'm going off on a tangent and
I'm late because I gotta go I gotta get
on the road I am going to the university
of Irvine today which is why this whole
conversation even started I'm just so
excited you better be there when I shake
watch me if I can stuff
[Music]
so the sports arena in lecture party
sports initiatives that we've done over
a UCI and it has multiple killers some
of that is competitive gaming we have
our own scholarship teams especially in
League of Legends and as you can please
behind me we have the UCI u Sports
stream corner so you can learn
Entertainment social media build and
market your own brand and then over here
is console corner so that's like our
smash a lot of our fighting game stuff
like that but it's multifaceted so it's
not just learning eSports we do have an
amazing computer science program it's
bigger than that
you just compete and you get to interact
as a student on campus this is like the
coolest thing ever so do you want
introduce yourself to my friends hey
guys I'm giggling over let's hear what
you major so I am a philosophy political
science and economics major
what's your game of choice most
importantly overwatch and I'm definitely
gonna Bastion main game cube over here
yeah it wasn't this is what this right
here this is why I almost failed College
GameCube Mario Kart we basically spent
like three weeks playing non-stop didn't
go to school didn't do anything but now
you guys have it here
did you can actually play as a part of
going to school console corner we have
like tons of different consoles so a lot
of the smash team will bring you know
their own weeds or their own game cubes
or whatever they want to play on just so
that they can practice
and we offer different cultures as well
Xboxes of NPs floors and anything you
want to get your hands on oh my god this
is incredible I mean this is this is the
future here so all of our scholarship
players they can come in before and
after hours if they need to they can
come in in between classes and they get
to be on their own dedicated computers
they have a scholarship program for
League of Legends that's what you're
telling me so awesome
so they get to they get their school
paid for to come flavor so it's not like
you're playing video games for fun I
mean this actually ends up turning into
sort of a job in a career and you're
playing for a completely different
reason basically to be the best yeah
absolutely no this is the start College
is the place where you go to prepare for
your career and I think the great thing
that you see is recognized is that
eSports is a huge huge future part of
these people's lives and they want to
prepare them for that career I love it
and look at those themes listen this is
it
[Music]
Alex hello so we were just chatting to
some students here at UCI and and we're
both well we're definitely older than
them and this is something that did not
exist back in our day going to school or
no I'm actually glad it didn't exist
because I would never have graduated
college but you would have because this
basically I mean you go to class and you
come here and play games and then it
just all works out by the way as you can
see they actually have like a stadium
that's like where the people play and
they are competitive like college
eSports is like legit a thing I was
talking to Paul and he gave me a quick
little tour and I mean we could actually
have scholarships yeah yeah
League of Legends fellowship so hey guys
you know what tell your parents this is
where you need to go you're not wasting
time tell your folks you're learning how
to get free college I love it this is so
cool
no games even playing a lot of over
white loud geometry season 10 just came
out I was told sex with Diablo 3 this
years ago that it's someone I really
know they pick everything that you
thought was wrong with it when it first
came out is so much about it is
addictive so were you saying I should go
back to the hablo sir yes I am Oh one of
my characters and hazard to 500 hours of
games on one of my character is that
from recently or from previously it's a
cumulative yeah but it took me a day and
a half to get 70 and see huh wow you've
got to come back a screen okay good
because and they're going to come out
with a necromancer so I basically have
not put down my Nintendo switch like I
was gonna bring it with me but I was
like I'm not going to be able to play it
and drive yeah this should be really fun
but yeah oh my gosh jello three oh my
goodness I'm having flashbacks and you a
while ago first came out I know I know
and they fixed so much stuff like your
system is so much better it's crazy
just try it you'll think okay perfect
have you played any switches did you get
a switch
I haven't gotten a switch because I get
these I get like I have an xbox one yeah
I have a ps4 we I didn't get the Wii U I
never play them anyway Diablo 3 World of
Warcraft overwatch here's the storm and
then whatever new computer games is out
let me tell you man the switch is so
great I know it's so great that
everybody
that I think I might have to go I think
you're going to have to honestly in
Zelda is such an incredible games it I'm
speechless
you guys already know how much I played
it plus I have Tesla so we're going to
find something to do while it's driving
me places that's true
that's not C not yet what is the head
soon yeah somewhere up days it'll be
like I can use the switch now well
that's it thanks for hanging out my vlog
[Music]
probably an all new low I just got home
two minutes ago from Irvine so before I
left I was like I'm gonna be hungry by
the time I get home so I basically
ordered post mates from the car and now
I have another visitor Jenn I was making
a video so what happened is I ordered
pulls me from the car so that by the
time I got home it would be here and
ready and waiting
here look I bruschetta you know what
what I can't have some carsick or like
not feeling well the other thing Jack
you do anyway it was so much fun and
when I said to these guys both Jenn and
I both went to school Jenna went to
school a lot longer than I went to
school one of the things that I learned
by going to school not only did I learn
the things that I'm interested in what
did you go to school for Jenn let's talk
about it I double majored in forensic
biology and biology so I have two master
degrees and a minor speech pathology
audiology baby
what do you know so I went to school for
multimedia a technology graphic design
video production basically everything
that I'm doing right now one of the
things that I feel like people think
that you have to go to school to learn
these things you don't but what I did
learn in school was working with people
meeting people having life experiences
and making some really good friends and
now I doubt it
we do baby what you do with what you
learn and the people and the friends and
the connections that you make in school
what you do with that after is what's so
important and I'm so excited for the
future of eSports like
I just I can't wait until more schools
embrace it
parents embrace it because there is a
future here and we're living in it right
now
so parents their watchings and your kid
is super into video games encourage them
to keep going with that passion they can
be a video game designer they can
actually get a scholarship now to play
video games in college I love the life
that we are currently living in right
now it's incredible I'm gonna eat my
salad and I'll see you guys later
so Wow peace out
oh god I almost lost my meal
[Music]